الهجوم في خانيونس يسير على نحو ممتاز
هكذا قالها رئيس اركان جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي هيرتس هاليفي الذي اكد ان
الطريق مازال طويلا للقضاء على حركه حماس
بث الجيش الاسرائيلي صورا للقتال في
خانيونس جنوبي قطاع غزه قال انها لوحده
كوماندوز عملت خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين في
عمق خانيونس واكد ان الوحده عثرت على
مخابئه هجوميه لحركه حماس ودمرتها كما
داهمت العديد من البنى التحتيه وعثرت فيها
على اسلحه ووثائق استخباراتيه حسب ما نشر
الجيش
الاسرائيلي المعارك في خانيونس يصفها
الخبراء العسكريون بانها تكسير عظام فجيش
الاحتلال دفع بخمسه الويه في المدينه وهي
الويه جفعاتي المدرعات كوماندوز والمظليين
و كفير مدعومه جميعها طبعا بوحدات من سلاح
الهندسه رغم توغل جنود جيش الاحتلال بهذا
العدد الكبير في المنطقه نشرت كتائب
القسام يوم امس مقطع فيديو جديد لاستهداف
دبابات وجنود اسرائيليين في خان
يونس
[موسيقى]
تداول كبير لهذه المقاطع التي اعتبرها
البعض تناقض تحركات اسرائيل العسكريه في
خان يونس دعونا نشاهد هذا المقطع الاخر
المتداول والذي يظهر رد فعل احد مقاتلي
القسام بعد تفجيره لدبابه
اسرائيليه الحمد لله انفجرت اقسم بالله
ولعت
ولعت الحمد لله ولعت الحمد لله ولعت يا رب
لك الحمد يارب يارب يا ار الحمد لله
الحمدلله الله
اكبر كيف علقتم على المشاهد الجديده التي
بثتها كتائب القسام دعونا نبدا هنا بعبد
العظيم اذا يقول عبد العظيم المعركه في
خانيونس مهمه جدا من يكسبها سيكسب الحرب
يبدو ان الاحتلال لا يقوم باي انجاز عسكري
هناك سوى التدمير بدافع الانتقام ماذا عن
رضا الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يدفع بكل قواته
نحو خان يونس يسندها بعدد من الجنود ولكن
المقاومه تدك دكا وسط ش خان يونس ما يعني
انهم لا يسيطرون رغم كل العتاد ماذا عن
شارد المعركه التي لا تحسم في ايام لا
تحسم في ايامها الاولى لن تحسم ولو بعد
عشر سنوات جميع الاهداف التي اعلن عنها
اول يوم لم يتحقق الى الان اي هدف منها
اخيرا نصل الى عبد الوهاب يقول اضافه لواء
اسرائيلي اخر اضافته هو هو خطا عسكري كبير
سيزيد النسبه المئويه للاصابه وايضا
سيضاعف الجنود الذين ستفترق قذائف الياسين
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اقر يوم امس
بمقتل سته عسكريين منهم ضابط برتبه ملازم
كان نائب قائد سريه خلال المعارك المشتعله
مع المقاومه الفلسطينيه في غزه ليرتفع
العدد الاجمالي لقتلى جيش الاحتلال الى
500 قتيل منذ بدء العدوان على غزه منهم
166 عسكريا منذ بدء التوغل البري في
القطاع